this video is sponsored by formation
stick around to hear more about how
formation is training the next
generation of top-level software
engineers or learn more at the link
below hello everybody my name is mayuko
and welcome back to my channel so this
is a question i get quite often in my
comments in dms about whether it's ever
too late to get into tech and
immediately my answer is always no it's
never too late to get into tech no
matter what life stage or age you are
but i wanted to make a dedicated video
on this topic and i'm guessing that
those of you who clicked on this video
are not really looking for like a
one-word answer and you're just trying
to get more perspectives on the matter
so that's what we're gonna talk about
today and as a lot of you know that's
not a part of my journey that's not
something that i've been through and so
i interviewed some folks who have been
on this journey to share their
perspectives and thoughts too so meet
dana um so i live in jacksonville
florida i am currently 48 almost 49
years old i was a travel agent for most
of my professional career so 20 plus
years in travel
on the personal side i'm married i have
a daughter she's 11 she's the light of
my life
and she was one of the reasons why i
decided to transition into a new career
i'm chris yeah my name's um chris i live
in the uh south of the uk two young
children are six and a three-year-old
married as well so um yeah i've been
married for a few years now we got
married in new zealand and then after
that we had a five-week holiday in new
zealand kind of in a camper van touring
north to south island and that was kind
of i suppose starting point of my
transition into tech i've recently
started an ios developer job at a
company called gcn so that's the global
cycling networks they're predominantly a
youtube channel but they've got a mobile
app for ios and android both chris and
dana were doing work that was vastly
different from software engineering but
they ultimately both decided to make the
switch because they wanted to do
something that they enjoyed and that
they were passionate about as their
full-time job i wanted to find something
i was passionate doing like i said i'd
worked at the pre my previous company
for
at that point about 10 years and by the
time i left it was about 13 years and i
kind of fell into that job from leaving
college it was it was a good job and it
paid well and i was reasonably good at
it but it was never something i was
really passionate to go to work to do i
knew i had been burnt out of doing
customer work so essentially i was in
the travel industry but it's very
customer-facing and i was hooked to a
headset for almost 20 years and like
immediately available to people and i
enjoyed being of service but at some
point you know especially with my
daughter being sick i began to not
attach such importance to getting
somebody where they needed to go and i
more wanted to go where i wanted to go
it became my turn to get to a certain
age to have lived enough of life to go
you know what i don't have to do with
somebody else that i might be good at i
can do what i want to do with my life
and even if i fail i can try this out
and i can see if i like it to find
something that you love to do
all day every day like in your mind
trying to solve something that you can't
figure out
was such a big deal for me for the first
time
i'm going to pick what i want to do i'm
deciding what route i want my life to
take and it doesn't matter if i have
like 20 professional years left or 40
professional years left i can choose
what i want to do with it so maybe
you're also in the same boat of wanting
to make that transition into a tech
career but one of the first challenges
and questions you might run into this is
is it too late am i too old for this
career change before we move on i want
to say a big thank you to the sponsor of
today's video formation maybe you're in
a spot where you have about one to two
years of engineering experience but
you're looking to land a top tier role
at barrier companies like google and
facebook and lyft and twitch if so then
you should definitely check out the
formation fellowship it was founded by
staff level engineers from facebook and
nextdoor who interviewed thousands of
candidates and wanted to create a better
way to prep engineers to perform the
best that they can once you apply and
get accepted into their three to six
month program you get a training plan
that's personalized to your specific
skill gaps with direct mentorship from
super senior engineers and you can get
referred directly into top companies in
the industry you can actually do this
fellowship part time and they also have
an income share agreement so that you
pay zero until you get the job you can
check out their program and apply for
free at formation.dev
myuco also linked in the description box
thank you so much information for
sponsoring actually super duper love
what they do and i've met so many people
on their team who are just amazing
incredible smart and kind people in fact
i've got a really exciting announcement
with them that's coming up in the next
couple of months that i think you'll be
really interested in i've also done a
mock interview with their ceo sophie so
that'll appear on their formation
youtube channel and social media so make
sure to stay tuned all right now let's
get back to the video okay so we're
going to talk about if someone is too
old to join tech let's first talk about
why the stigma is even there to begin
with yeah you do have that kind of i
suppose niggle in the back of your mind
that um
you know
might be too old because like you say
there is that that kind of idea that
people are a lot younger they're coming
out of school kind of thing or you know
university some of these people are
sometimes like 25 or something like that
and i'm thinking oh you know
i i started this journey when i was 32.
so yes definitely the stereotype of
someone in technology is like a young
person someone maybe in like their early
mid-20s i mean when you look at like
movies and tv shows and conversations
online about technology you know that
the audience is definitely younger and
so naturally i totally understand how it
can feel like there's like no one over
like the age of i don't know 35 40 in
tech spoilers there totally are i've met
so many of these people and they're all
great so like don't trust everything you
see online so the stigma is definitely a
challenge but it's also just like not
easy to hop careers either especially if
a tech career is maybe your second or
third or maybe even fourth career then
making that change is gonna be really
difficult because you're likely coming
from something that's already supporting
you and your family and your lifestyle
and that's scary because like why would
you leave something that's like already
working and of course if you have other
people to take care of then that's
definitely added pressure and
responsibility so how did chris do it i
have a very supportive wife which i
think really helps she was always very
encouraging of me going for whatever it
was that i was going for so that really
helped and my kids were too young at the
time but you know as they do grow older
i wanted them to see that you can do you
know what you are and passionate about
what you are what you do enjoy in life
as a as a job i suppose as well just
kind of went for it kind of thing and
and just hoped that it all worked out
and um i feel like it came at the right
time in life as well in terms of i've
done a lot of prep before as well and i
felt ready for that transition so and
you know one of the questions that came
up for me when i was thinking about this
topic is are people going to experience
ageism if they enter tech kind of later
in life and honestly your mileage may
vary like depending on which part of
tech that you join and what kind of
people you surround yourself with there
might be some really mean people but
it's also totally possible to be in an
area where there's a lot of nice people
who are never gonna say anything like
that to you about my age and then i
think if i had heard about somebody
who's 60 or later and then i remember
reading that article about somebody who
is like an 80 year old grandma that
learned how to code and she's like an
awesome
kick butt teammate and
i think no i don't think it's too late
if that's what you want to do i think
it's too late if you just want to make
like a lot of money but if it's what you
want to do go for it life's not over
until it's over we might as well live
our absolute best and make a bunch of
mistakes maybe you learn the wrong
language or maybe you use the wrong
resource or maybe you go to the wrong
boot camp you get closer to where you
want by by going through those
experiences no i definitely don't think
it's too late to ever start a career in
technology i the people i work with very
in asia from the younger end of the
spectrum kind of just starting out you
know we've got a back end developer
who's about 1920 and he's incredible but
then we've got people who are kind of
the
later
stage of their career as well and and
they're just as incredible as well the
only limitation i've had is myself
because i felt that way about me um like
i'm i felt like in the back like i might
be too old they're going to think i'm
too old but
the people that i i worked with in boot
camp and my instructors were like 20
years younger than me
or more and the people i coded with and
the people i was on internship with
they're great people and i love them and
one of the women that i worked with in
the collab lab
i think i'm older than her mom i mean we
get along absolutely great it's not a
factor for them it's like the only
limitation is
i believe in my mind if i were to
self-eliminate from everything i didn't
think i was qualified for every place i
didn't think i fit i would never try for
anything and that's just not what i
bought into i believe
in the mindset that i was taught that
i can make a career change
anybody can do it if they put in a
really whole lot of hard work
a whole lot so then if it's not too late
and you're not too old to make the jump
then should you and i think there's a
lot of things to think about here
because this is ultimately a big career
transition one of the things you might
think about is how you're going to teach
yourself how to code there's a lot of
different pathways like being
self-taught or going a coding boot camp
or going to a university i've in fact
made a video about some of those topics
that again i will link right here that i
hope are going to be useful and you know
no matter which path you choose it's
going to be hard all of these are very
challenging but i really think that if
you really want it then you're going to
be able to do it because you know what
let's be real it's not an easy task
there's going to be a lot of ups and
downs you have to kind of get used to
rejection because you're going to get
especially for somebody who's kind of
coming from a career switch you're going
to get rejected from pretty much
everything you apply for at the start
but that's really really fundamental to
your progression and your learning
because hopefully now i can't obviously
say all companies did this because not
all companies did but a lot of companies
will give you feedback on how well you
did what you could have done better the
job that i now work in was actually a
company i applied for two years ago the
developer who reviewed my take-home
project two years ago gave me a ton of
amazing feedback on the project and said
you know these are all the places that
you can improve go away and have a look
at these kind of resources et cetera et
cetera et cetera that was back in 2000
2019 i then met that developer at
hacking with swift live in 2019 and
obviously that was pre-coded so it was
an in-person conference and you know we
just talked and had a chat and then i
applied for the job again two years
later march last year i got offered the
job and the person who interviewed me
gave me all that that feedback is now my
peer programmer basically i work with
him every single day i speak to him
every single day one thing i really
wanted to kind of make sure i did was to
do things that continually put myself
out of my comfort zone just to try and
learn new things and expose myself to
new things but i also learned that maybe
if you have a lot of life experience
this won't actually be the hardest thing
that you've done i've been through a lot
worse um in my life um i'm 25 years
sober and my daughter had cancer i've
survived both of those things and my
life is better for both of those things
like i've been through a lot tougher
things than trying to find a role in a
new field i i find it gives me
perspective
i'm very grateful for every day that i
have my life could have turned out
completely differently i could never
have had a family i could never have
done half the things that i've been able
to do i'm just very grateful to be able
to have the opportunity to have one more
day with my kiddo to just try and be an
okay person and a decent person to be
around and in fact one of the advantages
that you have about coming from a
different life into tech is that you're
coming in with a lot of great skills
already it's just a matter of
translating those intangible skills into
ones that are relevant for the job so
yeah things like project management
planning learning new skills gathering
and providing feedback and maybe
enduring difficult and challenging times
those are all kind of honestly
underrated skills that a lot of people
in tech don't have so if you already
have them then you know you're on your
way up so i hope this video was helpful
in helping to provide some perspectives
and kind of really letting you know like
it's really not ever too late to join
tech even if you're like 80. in fact
there's this one lady that i met uh who
is from japan and she started developing
ios apps at the age of 80 and i got to
meet her at wwc and she was such an
inspiration and she was so cool but
thank you so much for watching the video
and a huge thank you to chris and dana
for sharing me with your stories about
doing that transition i'm actually going
to end the video with some advice that
they have for all of you about making
the switch don't forget to subscribe and
i will see you next time bye
the main piece of advice would be talk
to people there's so many times when
you're trying to do something and you
just think i'm never going to understand
this and i want i want to give up kind
of thing that's where the community
comes in at least for me i've
experienced a really encouraging
community and when you are struggling
you'll start to realize that we're all
in the same boat we are all struggling
in some way to have those people around
you to either encourage you or to even
if it's just to say
you know i'm a senior developer i've
been doing this for
20 years but i still had to google
how to put together a table view just
seeing those small bits of information
out there and talking to people out
there it really
just encourages you to keep going and
just and it just makes you realize that
yeah that we're all human and we're all
trying to figure this out together the
thing that's been most important to me
is listening to the inside of myself and
knowing that this is what i want if
someone's afraid and they're not sure
just check in on the inside and go like
is this something that i really truly
want because if it's something that you
want there's nothing that can stop you
from getting it absolutely nothing but
if you have an uncertainty that's more
based in i'm not sure if this is the
right thing i would say try
try it try a class try to learn a
language you know use some resources see
if you truly love it and if you do
it's just all systems go foot on the gas
never stop but if it's not what you love
you're gonna find what you do love i i
would never discourage anyone from
following their passion in their dreams
and it sounds so trite but
to me it means just the most
that
you know we only get one lifetime and
it's so short you have to absolutely go
for what you want